foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
in this video I will go over every
single wins of winter update ever since
George R Martin released his last novel
A Dance with Dragons and has a Song of
Ice and Fire Saga I think this is worth
looking at because it gives all of us a
better understanding of how much writing
he is or isn't getting done over the
last decade first I want to give a shout
out to The Insider website for Gathering
all of this information he has given us
a lot of updates over the years so I'm
sure it was an easy organizing all of
his various announcements alright now
let's look at every update George R
Martin has given about his long delayed
next novel The Winds of Winter the
highly anticipated sixth book in
Martin's A Song Of Ice And Fire series
has now been in the works for over a
decade since then HBO's Game of Thrones
series has ended significantly faster
than George R Martin was able to finish
his next novel HBO has released House of
the Dragon a show that has said over 100
years before the original series as well
as a myriad of other Game of Thrones
shows that are in the works George RR
Martin's A Song Of Ice And Fire series
however has remained unfinished over the
last decade the author has addressed
exactly how much he has done on the wins
of winter chafing against fan
expectations and doing his best not to
make promises his first of many updates
would start all the way back in 2010
when George R Martin released a Blog
stating that he already had finished
some chapters for the wins of winter now
keep in mind this was when he decided to
restructure A Dance with Dragons before
its release he said I guess this is a
good news bad news situation it's bad
news for those who want dance to be
really really long as long as Storm of
Swords are even longer what I have done
will make Dance 4 chapters shorter and
hey it's even good news for wins of
winter since I now have four chapters
done for that one in Arya asanza and two
Aryans this is of course assuming that I
don't change my mind again tomorrow and
move everything back the way it was last
week I am dancing boys and girls I'm
dancing as fast as I can but some days
it does feel as if I'm dancing in
circles in the very next year of 2011
George R Martin gave another update but
he did not give a firm answer for when
the fan and should expect the Winds of
Winter during his interview with
Entertainment Weekly Martin said he's
not going to say when the next novel
will be done there's an element of fans
who don't seem to realize I'm making
estimates I've always been guilty of an
excess of optimism he says he's already
made some Headway on the wins of winter
and expects to return to it in January
and fans can reassure themselves that
Martin is working for a conclusion since
he's often said he'll end the series
with a seventh novel now this next
update reveals how George R Martin
himself is a sweet summer child in his
2012 update he said he thought the wins
of winter would be released in 2014.
that's nearly a decade ago already when
he sat down for an interview with
Adria's news he said he already had
written about 400 Pages for the wins of
winter and that he was looking forward
to releasing it in 2014. interestingly
enough George RR Martin doesn't give his
next update until that same year he
thought he would release it in 2014.
this was when he started realizing Game
of Thrones was moving along much faster
than he could write his next novel in
the this 2014 interview at Vanity Fair
the author said he hoped the HBO series
would combine the narratives of the
fourth and fifth novels and the series
of Feast for Crows and to Dance with
Dragons It's My hope that they'll do it
that way and then long before they catch
up with me I'll have released a wins of
winter which will give me another few
years Martin said at the time it might
be tight on the last book a dream of
spring as they Juggernaut forward
so as you can see he had a lot of High
Hopes back then unfortunately not only
did Game of Thrones finish before him
but it looks like House of the Dragon
might as well now let's have a look at
his next update from March of 2015. when
he sat down with access online they
asked him about whether the show would
finish before him or not he said I don't
know I mean that'll be up to the fans
the show is moving forward and so am I
we'll see season 6 is still in the very
early stages he confirmed and certainly
we're months away from filming anyway
meanwhile I'm writing the Winds of
Winter I'm not done with it yet I still
have a lot to write but I also have a
lot that's already written so I don't
know I try not to worry about things
like this I just you know go in every
day and write the scene that I'm trying
to write that day and try to make it as
good as I can around this same time Game
of Thrones writers David benioff and dby
said the fact is we didn't want to catch
up obviously we would hope that the
novels would come out ahead of the show
but at the same time George has his
process and if it takes him 20 years to
finish the series then that's what it
should take he's writing to my mind a
great epic the greatest fantasy epic
anyway for our time so we can't rush him
and I wouldn't want to rush him and at
the same time we don't want the show to
go on a Hiatus in the very next month of
2015 George R Martin sat down with
Entertainment Weekly again during this
interview he said having the ones of one
or done before season six of Game of
Thrones has been my mission all along I
wish it was out now maybe I'm being
overly optimistic about how fast I can
finish but I did cancel two convention
appearances and I'm turning down a lot
more interviews anything I can do to get
it done he also said the way he feels
about the ones of winter is constantly
shifting saying that he oscillated from
thinking it was the greatest thing he's
ever done and that it's all garbage and
I should throw it all in the fire and
start again I'm sure all the stress that
was on him back then had him feeling
like a mixed bag of emotions now in the
following year of 2016 he wrote another
NADA blog announcing the wins of winter
was not done in January of that year he
said you all wanted an update well
here's an update you're not gonna like
it the Winds of Winter is not finished
believe me it gave me no pleasure to
type those words you're disappointed and
you're not alone my editors and
Publishers are disappointed HBO is
disappointed my agents and even the
foreign Publishers and translators are
disappointed but no one could be
possibly more disappointed than me for
months now I've wanted nothing so much
as to be able to say I finished and
delivered the ones of winter on or
before the last day of 2015 but it's now
another new year and the novel's not
done nor is it likely to be finished on
the next day or next week yes there's a
lot written dozens of chapters but
there's also a lot still left to right I
am months away still and that's if the
writing goes well sometimes it does
sometimes it doesn't so many chapters
still to write off course but also
rewriting I always do a lot of rewriting
I guess I could say sorry boys and girls
still writing and leave it at that it
will be done when it's done which is
what I have done more or less since well
forever then after a year of no updates
he finally said something to one of his
fans on the not a Blog website in
January of 2017. he said I'm not done
yet but I've made some progress not as
much as I hoped a year ago when I
thought I would be done by now I think
it will be out this year but hey I
thought the same thing last year well as
you all know the wins of winter still
hadn't been released by 2018 and during
an interview at the guardian George RR
Martin Finally Revealed how difficult
his writing had been I've been
struggling with it for a few years he
admitted the wins a winner is not so
much a novel as it is a dozen novels
each of them with a different
protagonist each having a different cast
of characters and antagonists and allies
and lovers around them and all of those
weaving together in an extremely complex
fashion so it's very very challenging I
thought that update was very alarming
because it not only revealed he wasn't
done but it also sort of indicated he
may no longer be enjoying his writing
then in Mar March of 2019 right around
when Game of Thrones was about to air
its final season he revealed he did not
know how the show would end because he
was only focusing on writing the novel
he said I haven't read the final season
and I haven't been able to visit the set
because I've been working on wins I know
some things but there's a lot of minor
character arcs they'll be coming up with
on their own and of course they've moved
ahead of my novels many years ago it
might be an end for a lot of fans he
said but it's not the end for me I'm
still deeply in it I better live a long
time because I have a lot of work left
to do only a few months after this he
revealed how he's working on several
other things while he's still writing
the Winds of Winter as you all know he's
been helping HBO develop other Game of
Thrones shows and he even did some work
on the Elden ring video game one is not
a Blog he said I'm writing winter is
coming I told you long ago and so it is
the ones of winter is very late I know I
know but it will be done I won't say
when I've done that before only to burn
you all in jinx myself but I will finish
it and then will come a dream of spring
how will it all end I keep hearing fans
asking the same ending as the show or
will it be different well yes and no and
yes and no and yes and no and yes I'm
working in a very different medium than
David and Dan never forget they had six
hours for this final season I expect
these last two novels of mine will fill
3 000 manuscript Pages between them
before I'm done and if more are needed
I'll add them and of course the
butterfly effect will be at work as well
those of you who follow the not a Blog
will know that I've been mentioning this
since season one there are characters
who never made it onto the screen at all
and others who died in the show but who
are still alive in the books so if
nothing else the readers will learn what
happened to a myriad of my other
characters both great and small that
viewers of the show never had a chance
to meet and yes there will be unicorns
of A Sort Booker show which will be the
real ending how about this I'll write it
you read it then everyone can make up
their own mind and argue about it on the
internet near the very end of 2019
George R Martin said he was focusing on
the wins of winter rather than spending
most of his days writing for House of
the Dragon over one is not a block he
said I'm not taking on any scripts until
I finished and delivered the wins of
winter winter is still coming and winds
remains my number one Focus as much as
I'd love to write an episode for House
of the Dragon in January of 2020 George
R Martin sat down for an interview with
the German news website this was when he
revealed That Game of Thrones fans know
one ending from the show but it's not
the real ending of his story the
creators of Game of Thrones have
overtaken me which I did not expect I'm
still doing what I've been doing for
years though I'm still finishing the
next novel The wins of winter first and
then a follow-up a dream of spring
that's what I'm focusing on after that
we'll see later that same year Martin
wrote that being isolated during the
pandemic may actually helped his writing
since he didn't have so many other
distractions I am spending long hours
every day on the ones of winter I
finished a new chapter yesterday another
other one three days ago another one
during the week before but no this does
not mean that it will be finished
tomorrow or released next week it's
gonna be massive and I still have a long
way to go now at the end of that same
year he said I was really on a roll back
in June and July and I've continued
since then but more slowly
I suffered a gut punch in early August
that really had me down for a time and
another for different reasons in early
September but I slogged on end of late
I'm gaining my steam again then in
February of 2021 it looked as if George
R Martin gave his greatest wins of
winter update when he said I wrote
hundreds and hundreds of pages for the
wins of winter in 2020. that's the best
year I've had since I began it why I
don't know maybe the isolation or maybe
I just got on a roll sometimes I do that
I need to keep rolling though I still
have hundreds more to write to bring the
novel to a satisfactory conclusion in
March of 2022 he then started to show
signs of what may be exhaustion or even
frustration when he said yes of course
I'm still working on the wins of winter
I've stated that a hundred times in 100
venues having to restate that endlessly
as worrisome I made a lot of Headway on
wins in 2020 and less in 2021 but less
is not none the world of Westeros the
world of of Ice and Fire is my number
one focus and will remain so until that
story is told however Westeros has
become bigger than the wins of winter or
even A Song of Ice and Fire In addition
to wins I also need to deliver the
second volume of archmaester gildane's
History Fire and Blood I am thinking on
aiming that one blood and fire rather
than simply fire and blood volume 2. I
got a couple hundred pages of that one
written already but there's still a long
way to go I've got to write more Duncan
egg novellas and finish their story
especially since there is a television
series about them in development not
only did it sound like he was sick of
discussing the wins of winter but it
also seemed as if he was ready to start
working on something else after all he
was mentioning all these other things he
wanted to write then in April of 2022 he
said the ones of winter will be the
largest novel he's ever written Bigger
Than A Storm of Swords and A Dance with
Dragons then in July of last year he
gave what might be one of my favorite
updates regarding his next novel he said
I will say this I have been at work and
my winter garden things are growing and
changing as does happen with us
gardeners things change new ideas come
to me old ideas become unworkable I
write I rewrite I restructure I rip
everything apart and rewrite again I go
through doors that lead nowhere and
doors that open on Marvels sounds mad I
know but it's how I write always has
been always will be for good or for ill
what I have noticed more and more of
late however is my gardening is taking
me further and further away from the
television series yes some of what you
saw in Game of Thrones will also be seen
in the ones of winter but much of the
rest will be very different and really
when you think about it this was
inevitable the novels are much bigger
and much much more complex than the
series certain things that happened on
HBO will not happen in my novels I have
Viewpoint chapters in the books never
seen on the show victorion Greyjoy
Arianne Martel Ariel hota John
connington and even Aaron damper they
will all have chapters and the things
they do and say will affect the story
and the major characters who were on the
show I have Legions of secondary
characters who also figure in the story
lady stoneheart young Griff marwin the
Mage Dark Star Jane westerling some of
those characters you saw on the show are
quite different than the versions in my
novels Yara Greyjoy is not OSHA gray joy
and HBO's your own Greyjoy is way way
way different from mine oh and there
will be new characters as well now they
won't be Viewpoint characters but with
all these Journeys and battles and
scheming to come inevitably our major
characters will be encountering new ones
and lands far and near not all of the
characters who survived until the end of
Game of Thrones will survive until the
end of A Song of Ice and Fire and not
all the characters who died on Game of
Thrones will die in A Song of Ice and
Fire some will sure of course maybe most
but definitely not all now I could
change my mind again next week with the
next chapter I write that's gardening in
the ending you will need to wait until I
get there some things will be the same a
lot will not no doubt once I'm done
there will be a big debate about which
version of the story is better some fans
will like mine While others like the
television show and that's fine however
I do fear that a certain section of the
fans are so angry about how long the
wins has taken me that they're ready to
hate the book before they even read it
that saddens me but there's nothing I
can do about it but write the best one
that I can and hope that when it does
release most fans will rate it with an
open mind and finally just last month
George RR Martin said and yes yes of
course I've Been Working On The Winds of
Winter almost every day writing
rewriting editing writing some more not
as fast as I would like and certainly
not as fast as you would like but he's
been getting more work done nonetheless
well there you have it ladies and
gentlemen that is every major wins of
winter update since George R Martin
started working on the novel I do wonder
where things stand at the moment given
it's been nearly a year since he said he
was roughly three quarters of the way
done let's all hope we don't have to
wait another three or four years since
it's been well over a decade for him to
make it this far
foreign
[Music]